[Musica]
cosa proviamo quando sentiamo parlare di
intelligenza artificiale e che cosa ci
chiediamo quando pensiamo ad un robot
come funziona oppure come si comporta
ma soprattutto quale sarà il nostro
futuro ecco queste sono state le mie
domande credo che siano le domande di
molti vedete prima di occuparmi di
tecnologia e di intelligenza artificiale
io pensavo che queste fossero qualcosa
di molto lontano da me per me l'uomo è
sempre stato al centro per il lavoro
anche che io svolgo
poi un giorno qualche anno fa incontra
una donna la donna 4.0 e da lì nascono
interessantissimi progetti sulla
tecnologia e nasce anche la community la
community donne 4.0 bene cambia il mio
punto di vista cambia la mia prospettiva
mi rendo conto improvvisamente che io
sono circondata da tecnologie
dell'intelligenza artificiale e non lo
sapevo
beh penso a quando utilizzavo il chatbot
di facebook piuttosto che i vocali il
vocale siri l'assistente virtuale oppure
le app presenti all'interno del mio
smartphone si pronte lì a darmi delle
risposte da alcune mie domande
beh mi rendo conto che ero circondata da
intelligenza artificiale e non lo sapevo
ne rimango stupita meravigliata e devo
dire anche affascinata ero circondata da
intelligenza artificiale
mi rendo conto che l'intelligente
artifici
e mi dava moltissimi vantaggi perché mi
consentiva di avere le risposte in
pochissimo tempo il con pochissimo
sforzo
dobbiamo dire che l'intelligenza
artificiale rappresenta l'emblema della
quarta rivoluzione industriale e da
grandissimi vantaggi nella vita
personale nella vita professionale
soprattutto nelle nostre aziende
sì perché vedete intelligenza
artificiale ci consente di ridurre molte
delle nostre attività soprattutto quelle
di tipo ripetitivo ci consente di
automatizzare i processi di lavoro ci
consente di essere più efficienti che ci
consente anche di migliorare il rapporto
con i clienti
la pervasività diciamo dell'intelligenza
artificiale ormai credo che sia un
processo inarrestabile credo che questo
sia una cosa condivisibile da tutti
la questione non è tanto condividere
convivere con i sistemi di intelligenza
artificiale
la questione è capire come possiamo
sfruttarli al meglio per la nostra
capacità decisionale ma soprattutto è
importante capire come possiamo
mantenere viva la nostra capacità
critica sì perché vedete l'algoritmo non
è neutrale perché l'algoritmo può essere
dati errati può essere portatore di
bahia se di pregiudizi che ci possono
indurre in comportamenti sbagliati
beh allora non possiamo né demonizzare
nel divinizzare l'intelligenza
artificiale tutto quello che possiamo
dire che l'intelligenza artificiale sarà
anche un nostro possibile alleato anche
per il futuro la mia curiosità si è
spinta nel cercare di comprendere quali
potevano essere le frontiere nuove
dell'intelligenza artificiale quelle che
potevano impattare maggiormente sulle
persone e sulle organizzazioni scoprono
l'intelligenza artificiale motiva ovvero
quel ramo della che attraverso la
tecnologia molto avanzata
dotata di sensori di alta tecnologia
consentono di leggere le espressioni
fatti
consentono di poter leggere la postura
consente di poter leggere il tono della
voce quindi programmati per fornire
delle risposte delle risposte adeguate
anche gli stati i motivi delle persone
beh allora mi chiedo e se il pensiero
logico razionale può essere riprodotto
dalla iii e se addirittura si può
arrivare a leggere anche quelle che sono
le emozioni di una persona
quali sono allora le abilità dell'uomo
che sono funzionali all'uomo per gestire
la complessità del nostro futuro che non
possono essere riprodotte da questa
tecnologia
beh io le vedo due l'intuizione è
l'immaginazione si l'intuizione è
l'immaginazione sono due abilità che
tutti noi abbiamo abilità dell'uomo che
ci permettono di gestire la complessità
ci permettono di gestire
l'imprevedibilità dei nostri tempi ai st
si diceva che l'intuizione è il dono
sacro e la razionalità il suo servo
fedele ma vediamo che cos'è l'intuizione
all'intuizione come dicevo appunto e una
capacità che permette di fare delle
analogie delle similitudini tra ciò che
conosciamo e ciò che non conosciamo è
quella capacità che noi mettiamo in
campo fin da quando siamo piccoli per
apprendere quello che ci succede nel
popolo che succede intorno a noi è una
scorciatoia cognitiva che ci consente di
poter risolvere problemi prendere delle
decisioni in situazioni di crisi di
incertezza
in effetti se ci pensate bene quante
volte ci capita di fronte a problemi
piccoli o grandi che siano di prendere
delle decisioni in base all'interno e
non in base alla ragione
a conferma di questo riporto quello che
la ricerca di due fondatori
dell'economia comportamentale che negli
anni 2000 hanno svolto una ricerca
un'indagine su come le persone
prendevano le decisioni in situazioni e
contesti di estrema incertezza
ebbene quello che ne venne fuori
sostanzialmente era che le persone
utilizzavano in quei contesti quelle che
vengono definite le abilità euristica
ovvero scorciatoie mentali acquisite nel
corso evolutivo del tempo funzionali
alla sopravvivenza
in effetti
se ci pensiamo l'eccessivo calcolo o
l'eccessiva richiesta di informazione in
situazioni in cui abbiamo necessità di
trovare subito una soluzione non sono
funzionali
beh vi faccio un esempio a me capita
molto frequentemente quando ha un
problema di cercare magari nell'arco
della giornata
tante informazioni affinché io possa
trovare la soluzione e per quanto la mia
ricerca sia spasmodica
spesso mi capita di non arrivare mai a
niente e allora magari sfinita mi corico
vado a letto
ed ecco che nel dormiveglia o il lampo
con la soluzione
ecco quella è l'intuizione andiamo a
vedere quella tra altra l'altra abilità
che l'immaginazione l'immaginazione
un'altra abilità che l'uomo ha e che le
sempre lo stesso einstein ci dice che è
più importante della conoscenza stessa
se vedete l'immaginazione è uno
strumento di conoscenza è uno strumento
di conoscenza che ci consente attraverso
la produzione di immagini mentali che
possiamo produrre trasformare sviluppare
ci consente di accedere a nuove
conoscenze a nuovi mondi
vi voglio raccontare l'immaginazione
sulla base di due specifiche funzioni
quella puramente immaginativa chi è
quella appunto di che c'è quella che ci
consente sostanzialmente di andare oltre
i nostri confini che conosciamo quindi i
confini della conoscenza e quella
l'altra funzione che è quella
visualizzati va la funzione visualizzati
va ci consente di recepire delle
informazioni ed acquisire delle
conoscenze di cose che non sono ancora
venute ebbene sì vi faccio un esempio
fate conto di immaginarvi di
visualizzare un bel piatto di lasagne
ecco quando facciamo questa operazione
le neuroscienze ci dicono che nel nostro
cervello si vanno ad attivare delle aree
che si attiverebbero nel caso in cui io
effettivamente mangiasse quella quella
lasagna quindi sempre neuroscienze ci
dicono che grazie ai neuroni specchio
che quando noi immaginiamo una
situazione con dovizia di particolari si
vanno a creare come dei circuiti neurali
e quindi la mia mente si va in qualche
modo di allenare tutto questo mi
consentirà quindi di acquisire
conoscenze nuove che mi saranno utili
per affrontare per quella situazione e
anche qua vi faccio un esempio
fate conto di dover fare un di parlare
in pubblico su un palco così come sto
facendo in questo momento e fate conto
che questa cosa possa produrre a voi un
disagio
ebbene se voi adottate la tecnica della
visualizzazione riuscirete a vedere
servì inc su quel palco riuscirete a
sentire l'emozione che proverete quel
giorno su quel palco
riuscirete a vedere le persone
riuscirete a vedere i volti delle
persone
ecco in questo modo la nostra mente
riuscirà a creare questa sorta di
allenamento e ci permetterà di
individuare poi che cosa devo fare per
poter affrontare al meglio quella
situazione
ebbene queste sono due abilità 2
capacità che l'uomo ha a disposizione
per produrre nuove conoscenze
ecco ma queste due abilitano necessità
di essere coltivata ed allenate beh
allora vediamo come l'intuizione
l'intuizione richiede un allenamento una
necessità di essere coltivata perché da
una parte richiede diciamo una
un'apertura all'uovo quindi uno
smantellamento di quelli che sono i
nostri schemi cognitivi che ci fanno
interpretare le cose soltanto da un
determinato punto di vista ci richiede
la curiosità ma soprattutto ci richiede
una cosa di acquisire sempre più
conoscenze sì perché guardate bene ci
possiamo affidare all'intuito solo nel
caso in cui si diventa veramente bravi
nella nostra materia
allora sì che questa abilità che
qualcuno definisce abilità superiore ci
potrà essere veramente d'aiuto per
affrontare situazioni di crisi
andiamo all immaginazione
l'immaginazione ha necessità anche
questa di essere coltivata e di essere
sviluppata soprattutto in un momento
storico nella quale domina il pensiero
logico razionale ma noi sappiamo quanto
nella sua funzione immaginativa
l'immaginazione è assolutamente
importante perché foriera di inventiva
ed innovazione e noi sappiamo quanto
lei ha necessità di di questo e poi
dall'altra nella sua funzione
visualizzati va ci consente di accedere
a quella potenza quelle energie
necessarie all'uomo per affrontare
situazioni situazioni nuove e
imprevedibili
quindi se io dovessi farmi la domanda
chi guiderà il futuro passerà sempre
l'uomo sarà sempre e solo l'uomo perché
vedete l'uomo non potrà delegare alla
intelligenza artificiale queste due
funzioni perché noi avremo sempre più
bisogno
nel futuro di avere persone che abbiano
sempre più abilità capacità di generare
nuove visioni nuove idee perché di
questo noi abbiamo bisogno abbiamo
bisogno per anche per gestire
l'imprevedibilità del domani